đồng tru khảo đã quyết định bộ xúc thêm một khăn bột giải thử mới, mang tên là phúc xử thầm lạng.
Đại đây là hàng một rõ chính hội đồng trung khảo chủ đất tìm kiếm và lửa trọng,
nhằm tôn vinh gái nhân và giữa án đã và đang tạo ra tắc độc tích cửa chó cộng đồng,
mằng sự bình bị bằng sự tất tâm và sự chuyên cả mứng mạnh mẽ,
dù họ thưa quý vị, chứa tình gửi hồ sơ để tham dự giải thưởng này.
Và với chúng tôi, đây chính là khác định giải thưởng hành động vì cộng đồng.
Có thể mở giống bằng tay, tìm đến và lăng toàn nhiều hơn nữa,
những giá trị nhân văn đang hành này được vun đất cho giá hồ t.
Hãy nhá hồn mấy em mà còn được nó được tham như thế mà còn trên đảo của mình.
Đó là nhá được đất kẹp cho một bình nhà như hồ trong khí đó,
nó phim của đủ ăn, nó bù lòng mà phải xây nghĩ hầu dơ bán của cái nhà,
thì có tình này để chặn lò cho tụi nó,
nhưng mà như dạ hồn màu, nó gàu màu, nó gàu màu, nó gàu màu, nó gàu màu, nó gàu màu, nó gàu màu, nó gàu màu,
và có là những chiếc xe rất là một màu, nhưng mà cũng nầy xuất động với mối chúng ta phải không thư cưới vị.
Đó không chỉ là câu chuyển của một con người mà còn là tinh thần phụ xu thâm lắm,
nó và đáng lăng tò, những giá trị nhân văn bình bị ở trong cộng đồng.
Tạ và để tiếp nối hạm một đặc biệt này,
thì thư cưới vị mắt tụi trách dạy thường hành động vì cộng đồng năm 2019,
xin chân trọng giữ thiệu, nhân vật thứ 2, được vinh dành ở hạm phụ xu thâm lắm,
ở một người, đảo dành hơn 2,5 cuộc đời để mang lại cơ hội đứng vấn và làm lại cuộc sống cho hàng linh với khu thật.
Tự kiểu đó chính là bác xí lây thành đô người thương bình người bác xí chính hình người lặng lẽ sản xuất và chào tạo miếng phi,
hàng linh chân tay dạ trong người khu thật nhau trên thấp tạn lưỡc,
và xí cứ vị chúng ta ấy cũng chào đón bác xí lây thành đô ở.
Bằng con xí mời bác bác sẽ đứng nổi lên xình trên trên này để mọi người ở tình gà mắt ở gió hơn nữa không à?
Bất ngạc
Và cho kê chúng ta đến với công xin nó, lấy bác lẽ thành đô,
thì sau này chúng tôi xí trên trọng ký mời đồng chỉ lẽ công mình,
ở ý viên chung nả, tổn biến tạm báo nhân dân,
khó chỉ văn tinh giáo và dân tạch chung hương,
chúng tôi có hội nhà báo Việt Nam và thực trường bán tổ chức giải thử thành đông vi cộng đồng.
Sai lên xin khấu để chào hạm một dài, phùng sự thâm lạc xí trên trọng ký mời.
Tứ tôi vì không chỉ giúp ý người biết tạp đi lại, lạo động thật tệ hơn,
mà bác xin nó có chú hợp vượt con mặt càng,
lấy lại những tin và phần giá cho cuộc sống,
xí lưu vì một chào và tay thật lón nữa không à?
Vừa là xin lời trên trọng kảm ơn đồng chỉ là lẽ công mình,
mà bác xin chào xin mời bác nó.